defense secretary Patrick Shanahan has
approved a homeland security department
requests for more personnel at the
southern border meanwhile President
Trump is about to make another major
proposal for what figures to be his main
really reelection campaign issue
immigration it involves a new way of
deciding who gets in and who does not
chief White House correspondent John
Roberts has specifics tonight from the
North long good evening John Brett could
evening to you in addition to a
signature issue of eliminating illegal
immigration President Trump is also
proposing major reforms to legal
immigration but so far those proposals
have met with as much opposition as his
plans to deal with illegal immigrants
White House staff are expected to
deliver to the president next week a
plan for merit-based immigration
president Trump insisting that the
current system is irreparably broken the
problem is you have 10 times more people
coming up with their families it's like
Disneyland now since the days of the
campaign the president has promoted
merit-based immigration similar to
Canada Australia and New Zealand he also
wants to eliminate the Visa Lottery and
chain migration Democrats have fiercely
opposed the president but the White
House hopes that may be changing we have
a number of unaccompanied children
skyrocketing the number of those
individuals coming across our border
being smuggled and taken advantage of
and Exploited and now members of the
Democrat Party hopefully are seeing
exactly what the president's been
talking about and we'll have a new
willingness to help us address it House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi Senator Chuck
Schumer and other Democrats will be at
the White House tomorrow for the first
time since January 9th when President
Trump walked out of their meeting on
wall funding infrastructure is the main
topic but immigration no doubt will come
up Customs and Border Protection is
preparing for a massive influx of people
now that word has gone out that
detention centers are full and people
are being released into the United
States if you come now and if you come
as a family or as an unaccompanied child
you will be allowed to stay you will be
released because our court system is so
backlogged
prevent effective or patreon even if
there's no right to stay in the u.s.
tackling a new problem Immigration and
Customs Enforcement is sending experts
in human smuggling to the border to
investigate incidents in which migrants
pose as parents and children to create a
faith family to exploit an immigration
loophole others are forging documents to
claim people are minors when they are
actually over 18 and the administration
is stealing for another fight with
Congress this time over Attorney General
William bars Thursday appearance before
the House Judiciary Committee Chairman
Jerrold Nadler wants staff attorneys to
question Barr about the Mullah report
after members of Congress have had their
turn there are valid reasons for wanting
to be able to have counsel ask questions
you know we've seen any number of
instances under the five-minute rule
where a witness will filibuster for four
and a half minutes and give an
unresponsive answer in the last half
minute and you can't follow up the DOJ
fired back not going to happen
in a statement spokeswoman Carrie ku
Peck saying the Attorney General agreed
to appear before Congress therefore
members of Congress should be the ones
doing the questioning he remains happy
to engage with members on their
questions regarding the Muller report
and late this afternoon the Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein
announced that he will be leaving the
department effective May the 11th back
in January Rosenstein said that he would
be resigning after the Muller report was
released in his resignation letter today
Rosenstein said the department made
rapid progress in achieving the
administration's law enforcement
priorities attorney general Barr he
preys on Rosenstein saying quote rod has
been an invaluable partner to beam
during my return to the department and I
have relied heavily on his leadership
and judgment over the past several
months
Brett John Roberts live at the North
Lawn John thanks